era un miércoles en la noche
cuando andrew a mi hermana la menor de
cuatro que fuimos nosotros y yo nos
fuimos a acostar
y digo acostaron a dormir porque antes
había que tener una plática de media
hora como suelen tener las hermanas en
la noche donde chisme vamos un poco pero
también platicamos de cosas muy
profundas intentábamos resolver el mundo
como se podrán imaginar andreas era
quien habitualmente tenía las preguntas
y yo que era la recién graduada de la
escuela de pedagogía de la universidad
panamericana evidentemente tenían las
respuestas
esa noche recuerdo que andra me preguntó
dos cosas muy profundas la verdad es que
creo que ni ni siquiera hoy google
podría contestarle esas preguntas andrea
porque sus preguntas eran sobre el
sentido de la realidad
me pregunto daniela te imaginas como
sobre el cielo
y yo después de haber cursado
antropología teológica uno dos y tres en
esta universidad deje pregunta - claro
que se el cielo andrea no es un lugar el
cielo es un estado del alma donde
coexistir hemos con dios contemplando su
belleza y su grandeza amando lo profundo
infinitamente bueno yo creo que la
convencí porque la segunda pregunta que
me hizo
me descolocó un poco y la verdad es que
hoy que después de 15 años la vuelvo a
pensar
me vuelve a sembrar
y me pregunto daniela tú crees que yo ya
me habré ganado el cielo
o sea le dije no
me encanta que te preguntes eso pero
andre en buena onda tienes 17 años no
has pasado calculo yo creo que te
convendría enfocar que ahorita en las
matemáticas porque estás a 6 meses de
terminar la preparatoria y ya luego
seguimos con este proceso que me encanta
que lo tengas en mente pero a ver tú y
yo sabemos que el cielo es el gran
regalo el gran premio para el que
estamos nosotros y bueno eso lleva su
tiempo bueno para acabarla si tú ya te
lo hubieras ganado no estarías hoy aquí
nos fuimos a acostar y yo tenía razón
esa noche este miércoles andra no se
había ganado el cielo
pero el viernes siguiente
dos días después sí
ese viernes andreas fue con un grupo de
amigos de la preparatoria a la feria
se subió un juego mecánico
desde el cual literal como dicen los
chavos
voló al cielo
un juego de caída libre falló a la red
y literalmente voló
esta experiencia no sé si es bueno o
malo
pero ha sido la más dura que me ha
tocado vivir
perder a mi hermana a mi amiga
a mi alumno más fiel
ha sido lo más duro que me ha tocado y
ahora se cambiaron los papeles porque
era yo quien tenía todas las preguntas y
que no tenía su hermana de la cama de al
lado para que le dieran las respuestas
me pregunte muchas cosas pero
fundamentalmente lo que me preguntaba
era cómo es que siendo tan cercanas
y ella había sido capaz de estar viendo
algo que yo no me había dado cuenta
ella estaba pensando en otra cosa
completamente distinta de lo que yo
estaba pensando
quien era andrea en realidad que con 17
años había sido capaz de merecer el
cielo
y quien diablos pensaba que era yo
para juzgar si sólo había ganado o no
en un afán por responderme a estas
preguntas vino a mi mente una frase que
habitualmente utilizamos en un sentido
negativo pero que para mí cobra un
sentido completamente distinto
esa frase de nadie sabe lo que pesa el
costal más que el que lo va cargando
me hizo muchísimo sentido pero no pensé
en el costal ni en la carga como algo
negativo que vamos cargando ni como un
peso que alguien nos ha dado y que
tenemos que arrastrar en la soledad
porque nadie sabe lo que vamos cargando
no pensé que ese costal es la misión que
cada uno de nosotros tenemos todos
nacemos con un costal un costal
potencial y personal
un costal que representa el único
equipaje posible que habremos de llevar
en nuestro último viaje hacia la báscula
de la felicidad
y digo potencial y personal porque es un
costal que no está hecho tú y yo cada
uno de nosotros tenemos que irlo
haciendo tenemos que irlo tejiendo a lo
largo de nuestra vida y tenemos que irlo
llenando a lo largo de nuestra vida
tenemos que irlo llenando de bienes de
verdadero peso
y para ello necesitamos nuestro tiempo y
nuestra vida y aquí podemos cometer el
primer error que yo cometí con andrea
cuando conteste a su segunda pregunta
tan abruptamente como contestamos los
que creemos que nos lo sabemos todo
y es pensar que nuestros años y nuestro
tiempo de vida es directamente
proporcional al peso de nuestro costal y
no es cierto andrea me enseñó que se
pueden tener 17 años no haber ido a la
universidad no haber pasado cálculo y
sin embargo tener un costal muy pesado
lo suficientemente pesado para volar con
él
cómo se logra un costal así
ella me enseñó que se necesitan dos
cosas lo primero es que bueno tenemos
que ir tejiendo este costal a lo largo
de nuestra vida un costal fuerte y
flexible y eso se logra con el rostro de
la vida con los problemas con las
frustraciones con los proyectos que no
nos van a salir con los sinsabores de la
vida
y a través de eso vamos a ir forjando
nuestras propias virtudes personales y
tendremos un costal lo suficientemente
fuerte y flexible pero un costal fuerte
y flexible no sirve de nada si no carga
algo de valor
hay gente que dedica su vida a acumular
en su costal bienes materiales
propiedades cuentas en el banco medallas
de maratón likes y está bien todas esas
cosas nos implican mucho tiempo y
también mucho esfuerzo pero no siempre
el volumen es directamente proporcional
al peso y soy pedagoga en esto soy
ingeniera
ni tampoco es la cantidad lo que hace el
peso dentro del costal que es entonces
lo que realmente le da peso a nuestro
costal andhra me enseñó que son tres
cosas las experiencias que vamos
viviendo a lo largo de nuestra vida pero
no es lo que experimentamos sino el
sentido que le damos a la realidad el
amor que ponemos en lo que hacemos en lo
que gozamos haciendo y las relaciones de
amor y de amistad que establecemos con
los demás y esto lo aprendí porque en
una ocasión a ella le encantaba tocar la
guitarra era bastante bohemia por eso no
estudiaba cálculo
y entonces fue con un grupo de niñas a
las que estaba ensayando para llevarlas
a un asilo en navidad' y que el cantaran
unos viejitos y entonces ella estaba
montando les el villancico ese día tenía
un concierto al que iba a ir un gran
trovador de aquellas épocas que ni los
digo porque me han de saber quién era
y entonces vivir con sus amigos y acá
entre nos iba a ir con su profesor de
música que era su cross
espero que no me halle las patatas hoy
en la noche por haber revelado su
secreto
y entonces yo que debe pasar por ella
para después arreglarla
ya saben la ilusión que tienen las
hermanas grandes de maquetar a tu
hermana y entonces le iba a peinar y
oliva maquillar y eso le dije pasó por
ti ahí donde estés ensayando a las niñas
y nos vamos para arreglarte pase y le
dije entra vámonos porque si no ya no
nos va a dar tiempo y me dijo sabes que
daniela no
es que sabes que las niñas están
desafinado y si más y no se saben el
villancico le dije bueno ya tienes el
caso de grabado déjales el cassette y
que ya se están ensayando con el caso de
mi hijo no porque son hace semanas mala
onda con los viejitos o sea es la posada
le dije a ver andra en buena onda los
viejitos ni van a escucharlo
da lo mismo y me dijo no es que sea mala
y dije ok en otra ocasión la contrataron
para cantar en un 16 de septiembre era
era su primer contrato profesional que
le había conseguido en la obra mi
hermana que es la encargada de las
relaciones públicas de la familia y
entonces se fue a cantar iba muy
emocionada y me habla por teléfono
llegando al lugar y me dice yo daniela
que crees que ya no me van a pagar tres
mil pesos dicen que a mí ya mi compañero
me van a pagar mil quinientos te
regresas no cantas
y me dice pero es que ya está la gente
en el restaurante no importa quedamos
que te iban a pagar tres mil pesos por
mil 500 pesos tú no vas a cantar agarra
tu guitarra y te vienes pues que yo sí
quiero cantar nada que dije así no se
pueden hacer negocios bueno ya se
entiende porque ella fue la que voló con
el costal y yo estoy aquí dando esta
plática verdad andra me enseñó que es el
amor lo que realmente genera frutos
dentro de nuestro costal y saben por qué
porque cuando establecemos relaciones de
amor somos capaces de generar vínculos
con las otras personas y esas relaciones
son realidades vivas y como realidades
vivas son capaces de generar frutos no
solamente en nuestro costal sino en el
costal de los demás no sólo durante
nuestra vida sino después de ella
el día del funeral de andrea
llegó de pronto un autobús
y bueno pues en los funerales siempre
hay varios difuntos que están velando y
dijimos pues ese autobús no es de
nosotros y se bajaron unas personas que
efectivamente no conocíamos y se
acercaron con nosotros y nos dijeron que
eran un grupo de personas que venían de
la sierra gorda de querétaro
que se habían enterado de la muerte de
andrea y que pertenecían a una comunidad
a la que ella año con año iba con un
grupo de niñas a hacer una labor social
durante el verano
la querían tanto
y se sentían tan agradecidos con ella
que fueron capaces de rentar el autobús
y venir a saludarnos a nosotros que no
nos conocían
solo por gratitud y por cariño
si el tiempo que tenemos nosotros es el
recurso más importante que tenemos para
llenar nuestro costal no podemos
perderlo no podemos darnos el lujo de
guardar cualquier cosa dentro de nuestro
costal y lo primero que necesitamos
saber es para que tenemos este costal
quien no tiene clara cuál es la misión
de su costal saben que camina con él
aquí de frente porque no sabe qué hacer
con él va comparándolo con el de los
demás viendo si el suyo está más grande
si está pequeño si está roto si está
fruncido y pasa el tiempo
comparándose con los demás sin llenar su
costal y así como se le pasa el tiempo
se le pasa la vida y se le pasa su
felicidad
eso no me lo enseñó andrea
esto me lo enseñó javi un amigo de
andrea
que le acompañó ese día a la feria iban
juntos solo que habiba unos lugares más
adelante que ella en la fila y se subió
primero
y entonces escogió el mejor lugar escogí
hasta adelante donde todos querían
porque era donde se sentía más padre y
se veía mejor
andrés quería ese lugar
y como javier ya eran tan amigos y la
quería tanto
dos minutos antes de que arrancar el
juego
le dijo bueno allá andrás te dejo mi
lugar
y se sentó en ese lugar
y cuando todo pasó
javi se dio cuenta que la vida
y su amistad con andrea le habían dado
una segunda oportunidad
y saben que fue capaz de decirle sí a
esa misión que sabía que tenía su costal
a esa vocación personal que sabía que
tenía y que no había tenido el valor de
decirle que sí
hace tres semanas aproximadamente
javi se ordenó sacerdote y hoy está
llenando su costal de bienes de
verdadero valor y peso
y tú
estás listo para poner en la báscula a
tu costal
[Aplausos]